Sterling plunged to near parity with the
US dollar early on Monday the pound
dropping by 4.85 percent to a dollar and
three cents that fall on top of a 3.6
drop last Friday investors and analysts
clearly skeptical of Friday's shock and
all mini budget by the UK Chancellor
quasi quateng
th okay there's a lot of indigestion in
terms of the amount of of debt that will
come online and given that we are of
course a current account deficit nation
that means that we are reliant on
International Savers foreign Savers to
really fund that deficit and if they
don't like the fundamentals in the UK
that are lined up for them well they
don't have to fund it and that's why
Sterling has been on this downward path
what spooked investors was Friday's
announcement at the UK's biggest tax
cuts in 50 years cuts that will be
funded by 48 billion dollars in extra
government borrowing
walking between government officers
flanked by an assistant the UK
Chancellor declined to comment on the
Market's turmoil Chancellor what are you
going to do about the turmoil on the
markets this morning sir
I'm not going to make any comment now
thank you
but late in the afternoon a statement
was issued to try to calm investors it
emphasized that unlike Friday's
announcements further upcoming policies
due in October and November will be
assessed by the independent forecasting
body
the opposition labor party is here in
Liverpool at its annual conference and
quasi quaten's opposite number Rachel
Reeves poured scorn on the government's
policy of trickle-down Economics she
said quasi quateng was Fanning the
Flames of a national emergency
it gives me great pleasure to introduce
our shadow Chancellor
Sterling is down
that means higher prices as the costs of
imports rise
the cost of government borrowing is up
that means more taxpayers money will go
into paying the interest on our
government debt
and in turn that means the cost of
borrowing for working people will now go
up to
with higher mortgage repayments for
families the government's plan to
kick-start growth by cutting taxes
appears to run entirely counter to the
bank of England's efforts to control
inflation amid intense speculation the
bank may call an emergency meeting to
raise interest rates the bank issued a
statement saying that the regular
scheduled meeting would be sufficient it
did though say it wouldn't hesitate to
raise interest rates if required I think
until that fundamental headlight so to
speak between what the fiscal side is
doing and the central bank is trying to
do I think once that equation is
resolved then only we get more clarity
on where the UK economy and UK assets
are headed by mid-afternoon Sterling had
recovered its early losses and was
trading at a dollar eight but that's
still more than 20 percent down on its
value of a year ago and the turmoil
appears far from over Paul Brennan Al
Jazeera Liverpool